talvez ela agora é com vocês mas o
placar em 3 a 1
muito obrigado e à igreja
vamos começar então se embora nós então
pra começo de conversa
nós nos questionamos de que serve qual é
a relevância da narrativa de histórias
nesse mundo contemporâneo que é
completamente dominado pela imagem
traduzindo pra que contar histórias
aí eu diria para vocês levantando uma
simples questão né nós estamos aqui pra
falar da arte de contar histórias
o que seria a arte de contar histórias
eu diria que seria a arte de encontro
encontro e aqui nós estamos nos
encontrando para contar histórias e o
princípio da contação de histórias da
narrativa está junto com a a1 o
princípio da linguagem na medida que se
desenvolveu linguagem se desenvolveu a
contação de histórias e o autor e
contador de histórias chamado team
boletim ele disse que a primeira
história que nós ouvimos é quando somos
crianças ea nossa mãe nos pega no colo e
faz um acalanto essa é a primeira
história
já a profissão do contador de história
um outro escritor chamado luis sepúlveda
ele diz que é a profissão mais antiga
até mais antiga que aquela a outra é
verdade
temos também que falar que cada povo que
cada estado país um determinado tempo
elege os seus contadores de histórias e
esses são responsáveis por transmitir
saberes histórias e muito mais
essas pessoas tiveram sempre nomes
especiais em cada cultura quais elas
pertence
na grécia antiga os a reduç rápidos
outros na áfrica eram os griôs aqui no
brasil em algumas tribos alguns povos
indígenas são os puxas
aqui em lages são o brilho testa
como diria o leo tolstoy um grande
contador de histórias o escritor russo
que comungando com todos esses
contadores de história ao longo do tempo
no qual eles têm em comum o fato de
sempre cantar em falarem da sua aldeia
do seu povo tolstoi dizia se querem ser
universal
kant e ame a sua aldeia
e foi assim que começamos no princípio
do trabalho
nós tínhamos mais perguntas do que
respostas
o caminho que nós escolhemos foi
aprofundar na nossa cultura e nos
perguntamos quem somos
para responder essa pergunta de quem nós
somos fomos pesquisar lá na nossa
família nos nossos ancestrais a nossa
raiz e surgiram algumas coincidências
a começar pelo nome gilson e adilson
adilson e gilson ambos nascidos em
famílias de muitos irmãos ambos quando
esperados pelas suas mães
esperava-se que fôssemos meninas o
adilson inclusive esperava sequer fosse
menino ele tinha um enxoval cor de rosa
e tinha até nome escolhido o nome do
evento era para ser
morgana eu tenho apenas uma irmã
somos em seis de cinco homens e uma
mulher e o nome dessa irmã por
coincidência é morgana a não é
direcionar o o meu pai se chama
francisco mas a minha mãe se chama maria
o pai do adilson se chama miguel mas a
mãe se chama maria na minha família tem
um histórico a wobben zia aliás o bisavô
dizia o avô dava remédio na família do
adilson o pai foi tropeiro contava causa
o avô foi recomendada dor de alma e
essas coincidências foram-nos
construindo ambos tínhamos vontade de
viver de teatro viver da arte
o caminho que nós escolhemos foi contar
história
no princípio lemos estudamos as
histórias universais
contamos as histórias da literatura
infantil até que um dia saindo de uma
apresentação um amigo de são paulo o
historiador chamado de mas que morava em
lages chegou e falou pô cara porque
vocês não trabalho com a literatura
regional e nos apresentou a literatura
de tito carvalho de guido wilmar sassi
enesa atanásio edson baldo
nesse momento nós começamos a abrir os
olhos e à vontade o anseio de trabalhar
com as coisas da nossa terra
ok ok já sabemos mais ou menos que tipo
de história que nós iríamos contar agora
como é que nós vamos colocar esse tipo
de história
como é que o negócio de fazer a história
de contar quem vai contar essas
histórias
aí nós tínhamos uma pista nós somos
seres vindos do teatro a formação
artística provém do teatro e logo teatro
eu tenho segredo para compartilhar com
vocês
aprendemos com os mestres da palhaçaria
com os palhaços com os klaus um segredo
muito importante que quando você coloca
uma máscara ela esconde o teu rosto
porém ela revela a tua alma e aprendendo
com eles que usam a menor máscara do
mundo apenas um nariz vermelho
nós entendemos que para nós conseguimos
revelar as nossas maiores virtudes
nós tínhamos que mostrar os nossos
maiores defeitos e assim começamos eu
tive uma infância muito boa
muitas brincadeiras gostava de brincar
sozinho a minha família humilde
meu pai trabalhava em uma madeireira a
minha mãe era empregada doméstica e
tinha os vizinhos que poderemos dizer
que eram ricos né ricos de bens
materiais mas faltava a companhia de
amigos e pessoas para brincar e assim
eles faziam me buscar em casa para
brincar com eles muitas vezes
tava afim de brincar mas mesmo assim eu
ia lá nós fazemos a divisão de renda
porque eu tinha bastante irmão eles
tinham bastante brinquedos
eu não queria brincar e brincava em
troca de brinquedo e lá nós fazíamos
várias brincadeiras tipo estourar a
bombinha no galinheiro opa taca fogo na
casa né cassapo e teve uma vez que eu
peguei e soltei um boi bravo atrás da
avó daqueles meninos que me leva a uma
brinca
aquela mulher eu só lembro aquela cena
da mulher correndo chacoalhando e
gritando mas é o grilo seco do diabo né
e naquele momento toda vez que eu fazia
uma bagunça aquela mulher me chamava de
grilo seco hoje e eu agradeço a ela pelo
apelido e agradeço também pela
experiência e se não fosse o grilo seco
também não teria uma história pra contar
de revelar as minhas virtudes a partir
dos meus defeitos
pois bem eu morava em otacílio costa eu
vim pra lojas pra fazer faculdade e
nessa época eu comecei a perder o cabelo
continua perdendo até hoje
pena que você perde nunca mais em conta
o fato é que eu sempre tive essa cabeça
grande tem consciência disso e eu
comecei a ficar calvo vim para cá fazer
teatro perder cabelo fazer conta a
história fazer faculdade e assim por
diante
e um belo dia lá estávamos nós no ensaio
éramos em 3 naquela época já tinha o
grilo seco tinha um outro parceiro
chamado roupa e fuça e tinha eu ainda
sem um nome sem o apelido oficial e o
grilo seco olhou bem no grande meus
olhos como diz olá diana e disse mais
hoya está o nome do céu além de é a
cabeça grande é texto parece até um
testa de alencar 1
eu fiquei tão brabo fiquei tão indignado
com aquilo que o apelido pegou na hora
aí não teve jeito depois daquele dia
sempre que a conta a história tinha o
cabelo seco e o testa de lampião e assim
valorizando os nossos defeitos
nós buscamos reforçar nossas qualidades
trabalhamos aquilo que teoricamente
seria negativo para se tornar muito mais
positivo mas agora me corta uma coisa
grilo e que histórias nós contávamos que
histórias conta aí nós tínhamos a
experiência da literatura infantil a
experiência da literatura regional
aí vem uma outra pergunta ea história do
mestre mi do seu tatão do seu joão quem
é que vai contar porque a literatura
escrita está nos livros basta que a
gente tenha o interesse vai buscar está
na biblioteca pública ea história dessas
pessoas
a partir daí então nós assumimos a
responsabilidade e o desejo de aprender
com os nossos mestres de cultura popular
e aprender com a tradição oral
isso nos levou a muitas viagens nós
viajamos para diversos lugares
inexplorados são josé do cerrito urupema
capão alto ponte alta ponte alta do
norte ou seja fomos pro interior
fomos pra a zona rural e lá nós
descobrimos uma verdadeira
biodiversidade de causos que nós
aprendemos a catalogar classifica e
contatem lá causos escatológicos que são
aqueles que vão aprender vão falar das
funções mais primárias do ser humano e
assim por diante
temos também causas de assombro é o caso
da mãe de ouro o caso da mulher de
branco causa do billy some e até uma
modificação genética agora que elmo
isome e também tem muitos causos que
depois vão falar da vida alheia causa de
gente que fala da vida de gente mas não
é fofoca que fique claro é só por
interesse e aí por último tem aquele
tipo de causa que nós identificamos que
é o caso mais cestrone uso que aquele
causo mais comovente que é quando a
pessoa tem a confiança de contar uma
história que aconteceu com ela mesmo uma
história da sua própria vida e aí nós
descobrimos uma outra coisa importante
que essas viagens todas que fizemos no
nosso mundo nos fez conhecer o
território
muito mais para além do território já o
político das distâncias e quilômetros
nós entendemos que o território da
cultura ele permeia o território da
cultura ele passa pela memória ele passa
pelo dito pelo não dito pelos afectos
pelos rancores pelos saberes pelos
fazeres porque é inerente às pessoas
onde existe uma sociedade onde existe
gente convivendo existe o território da
cultura e é nesse território que habitam
as histórias e que habitam a todos nós é
ben ali que nós estamos descobrindo isso
descobrindo nesse território da cultura
onde tirar o substrato de histórias é
que nós entendemos que quando contamos
uma história que acontece aqui nessa
região
de certa forma nós contamos todas as
histórias do mundo
assim a gente também entendeu que ter o
convívio com a tradição oral é ter
licença dos deuses a bênção dos mestres
para reinventar a cultura
vou pedir licença pra vocês pra contar
uma pequena história e essa história é
mais ou menos assim
esta história é a história de um menino
comum como outro qualquer
até o seu nome era comum se chamava joão
+ joão tinha um sonho em comum brincar
com as estrelas lá no céu
disposto a tudo para conquistar o seu
sonho subir um morro mais alto na escada
mais longa e nada conseguiu resolveu
então falar com seu avô meu querido avô
como faço pra chegar lá nas esteiras lá
no céu tudo já tentei mas nada adiantou
o avô olhou para o menino sorriu e falou
que quando pequeno as mesmas coisas ele
tentou ea única maneira de brincar com
as estrelas lá no céu é com os olhos e
com imaginação
por isso o chamavam de mata que ter anne
os olhos que ficam as estrelas
essa história de autoria do adilson
freitas do brilho seco
e fala do nome da nossa associação da
associação que fundamos e pra finalizar
já que nós trouxemos aqui uma história
local eu queria compartilhar com vocês
uma história universal do eduardo
galeano se falou hoje do mar se falou da
beleza de ver o mar
e ele conta que santiago morava no
interior com seu pai e não conhecia o
mar
um belo dia o seu pai pegou um ônibus
passaram horas viajando até que chegaram
nas praias do sul que ficam atrás de
dunas
o ônibus parou santiago pai desceram
foram subindo lentamente aquelas dunas
de areia sentindo o vento batendo no
rosto e quando chegaram lá em cima que o
menino recobrou o fôlego
abriu os olhos e contemplou aquele mar
azul refletindo um sol e as ondas
brancas batendo e chegando até na praia
ele começou a ficar emocionado ele não
conseguia articular nenhuma palavra
finalmente quando depois que ele
conseguiu soltar o fôlego e falar alguma
coisa ele pegou na mão do seu pai e
disse pai me ajuda a olhar a gente
complementando a arte de contar a
história é uma arte acessível a todos
basta que exercitem no início do nosso
trabalho quando terminávamos uma
apresentação a gente sempre dizia que
muitas vezes nós somos os olhos e que
nos assiste
nossas estrelas muito obrigado